[Music]
you my monkey butt [ __ ] lighter sweet
cheating funny
I'm your daddy next ticket doodle baby
boo honey I'm gonna say it again when I
started doing music it wasn't I just set
out to rap even my producer that time he
said you need to spit real about your
life who you are and so I came out to
him I'm like what are you you know I'm
gay
what if I spit about that he's oh I
didn't do it that's what you got to do
I'm Joey Lamar aka deadly and I'm a
rapper oh and I'm a gay
so baby baby I'm Yours dirty habits foul
mood back in early 2000 when I started
doing this stuff no one had ever seen an
open gate wrapper to them I was only
supposed to be like a masculine guy
that's doing it and spitting about
chicks and this but I was taking the
further back with my rap I mean I was
thinking more about Public Enemy I was a
big fan of Rage Against the Machine well
I mean they can make change with their
music and that's so that's kind of what
I was doing to my early fans were not
the people who I expected I thought it
was going to be hip hop heads be brown
and black men but it wasn't that and it
kind of made me mad because you know I
really wanted my brown and black people
that loved me and liked what I was doing
but I was dealing with a lot of people
that were down low and they had to
because that's just whether we were
brought up in the culture they say for
better for worse the baby baby oh dirty
when I first came out to I thought I was
gonna get a lot of love from the gay
community and it was the hardest thing
to crack and even the festival's I tried
to play Long Beach tried to play la
pride and every time they're like you're
a little too hardcore we don't want that
element here and I'm like but I'm gay
what element are you talking about
they don't understand that there's gay
fools that look like me and we're not
gonna go cause problems manages this is
the way we look good I tell you it's a
love song it's a gay love something like
you said I'm sweet man you know what I
think it just takes time you need to
talk to people and people need to live
beyond the surface man and I'm guilty of
that too man you know I think we're all
guilty it's just human nature man I
think we all want to put everyone in a
box and what's cool now - it's like dude
they're not looking at me as the gay
rapper they're not trippin on the whole
gay
you just do music
[Music]
I am Sabina 'has I am a Syrian gay
refugee activist before the war it was
not safe at all for me to walk around
the Qaeda came into my hometown and they
said they will apply Sharia law and
cleanse the city of all like sodomite I
expected to immigrate I did not expect
to run away
[Music]
I am an advocate for LGBT and alpha T
refugees rights when I went out from my
country I found that the peace of mind
and the safety that I felt I wanted
everybody else to feel the same I want
them to feel like safe Syrian LGBT faith
double discrimination you're scared to
save your life
yes caved your family rejection and then
to find your true self it is difficult
to relive your life but sometimes it's
healing you start to realize how bad
things were and how good they will be in
the future the Castro is a place where
you can be whatever you want to be it
may give you this courage to come out to
yourself and be who you want to be and
the person that you're supposed to be I
always thought that home is a location
but home is where your friends are where
your love is if home is not that then I
don't think I'll find anywhere else
in the dressing room something happens
while I'm getting ready once I start
putting my makeup on I turn from this
male to female and that is amazing for
me
[Music]
[Music]
my name is Cassandra luxottica
I am a professional wrestler I've been
wrestling for 28 years I'm an exotic
Oulu teller which is a flamboyant
wrestler with glamour and style
[Music]
I always knew I was different I remember
when I was in second grade I think I was
like 7 or 8 years old and I already knew
I was I was gay I was taught that I
couldn't be gay I couldn't act this way
I couldn't dress this way I couldn't
talk this way because I was gonna bring
help when I was first called to be an
exotic car I was like wow freedom this
weighted that i've been carrying for
years was just like melted down
rhinestones rhinestones
glow-in-the-dark I started using the
pantyhose the makeup the bathing suits
rhinestone feathers and boas and all
that because I wanted to be different
and that was the scariest moment but
when I saw the audience and the fans how
they took me in they were just like wow
look at him
her.she I feel like a woman inside and
then it's like this is me and that
transformation is beautiful
[Music]
something happens when I get out of the
dressing room to the ring I'm still
looking like a woman I'm looking
flamboyan and then once I step in the
ring my macho sigh kicks in I'm actually
gotta be ready for the fight all my
title matches and mostly all of our
matches has been against men masked men
like G stars over four pegs and I've
always been true to myself
it's Lucha Libre and not a beauty parlor
even though it looks like it sometimes
today I can tell you that being gay has
been a gift from God to me and I
understand that so that's why Lucha
Libre has always been one of my biggest
medications I don't think I will ever
leave me calibrate this is what I've
done all my life
[Music]
you
[Music]
I would come into church and preach that
God loves me that God accepts everybody
and I didn't believe that for myself I
was walking around wearing a mask
[Music]
I'm Reverend Eric terry pastor singing
Peters UCC and I am a black gay man
ministers so for a lot of people the
idea of being black gay and Christian
are three intersectionalities that
cannot come together I was 19 when I
accepted my call to preach in the
African Methodist Episcopal Church I was
the fifth generation of my family at
this church in its bylaws says you can't
ordain someone who's gay as a minister
you can't attend perform or condone gay
marriage I knew that there was not a
place for me I didn't want that life I
didn't want the sneaking the hiding the
seediness
of not being able to be accepted for who
I was as I was I resigned was I resigned
I found the United Church of Christ and
so today the idea that we're looking at
is that I when I first applied to be the
pastor of the church I was very nervous
and I didn't think that they would hire
me and I said I'm gay I'm young I'm
black if I said okay
it is extremely liberating to be able to
come to church to be able to stand
before people and to be loved and
affirmed for who I am as I am without
hesitation without fear and knowing that
it simultaneously empowers others to do
the same
[Music]
there are articles all around the world
with pronouns like he/she/it they a lot
of people just are not quite sure what I
am and honestly a little mystery is kind
of fun
[Music]
I'm Rayne dev and I'm a model activist
and general enjoyer of life so I model
as both a male and a female or in both
menswear and womenswear I worked as a
male bartender I've worked as a
firefighter for a while
under a male persona I've done
landscaping as male Oh I did power
washing for a while at Long Island I
feel like every day that I do more
modeling every day that I say I'm not
going to stop doing what I'm doing it's
another day in which I'm representing a
community that isn't stopping what
they're doing either my mission is not
to look fancy my mission is to show
people that they belong that they are
beautiful that they are handsome that
they are attractive and that they
deserve to be elevated it is hard to
protect yourself from being exploited
and turned into a gimmick by designers
who are trying something new or trying
to get a bang for their buck but at the
same time in a weird way I really want
to be exploited I want somebody to say
yeah let's try a gimmick because I want
them to see how wildly successful that
gimmick is I want them to start putting
people that look like me or that people
that are different on the runway
regularly I'm really hoping that people
see that I'm not a model I'm a movement
I'm a human and like that's it
[Music]